Third strategy is mediators. In mediator situation,
a new implementation element is introduced for
each invariant. And it's called a Mediator. Each Mediator is responsible for
maintaining one invariant. And knows what the dependent components are.
The independent event receiving component knows only that they
must inform the mediator, when their attributes change value. For example,
when the Scrollbar is adjusted, it alerts the relevant Mediator. Which in turn,
requests the new position from the Scrollbar. The Mediator realizes the new
content is required from the FileManager. Requests it, and pass it
to the ViewPort. That is each Mediator has knowledge and responsibility for
the maintain, maintenance of one invariant. And by the way, Mediator is
an example of a design pattern. Which we will explore later in the course.